[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Paul is
with us in Minneapolis hey Paul welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave thanks for taking the call
I have another should we pay off the
house early out of our retirement
question for you okay why is this one
different
um well we're my wife and I are both
retired uhhuh I'm I'm 61 she's 58 we
retired with the mortgage mhm and I've
got a number of differing opinions from
our financial guy I've Got Friends that
work in the finance industry I worked
for a banking 30 years and um I guess
just looking for another opinion maybe
one with a little bit more Credence than
some of the others I guess okay so how
much do you ow in your
home uh so it's a
$450,000 house we owe 170 and how much
do you have in your nest
what's that how much what's your net
worth what do you have in your nest
EG um net worth is about a million and a
quarter we've got just over a million of
that is uh investment and retirement if
your house was paid off if your house
was paid off why would you go borrow on
it uh we would not then what's the
difference I I gu it's
just okay let me rephrase the question
maybe a a better question is if we
decide to do this is it a process over
multiple years to ease a tax burden do
we just bite the bullet and take the hit
and do it once or how how would I do it
I've been doing this 30 years I've never
had anybody call me back and say they
were pissed off because they paid off
their
house fair
enough so one shot or would you uh I'd
write a check today I'd be debt free I'd
have been debt free yesterday if I were
you and quit listening to all these
idiots there's a lot of idiots out there
running around with an opinion about
your money and you're a
millionaire what's your mortgage payment
right I'll I'll go ahead what's your
mortgage payment right
now mortgage payment is what 1,200 okay
you'd freay up most of that which then
now you can invest so yes you'll lose
some out of that investment account but
you're going to still invest for the
next 20 years dude you're just going to
sleep so much better tomorrow I mean
we're both retired so invest is rolling
not necessarily additional you have
almost zero risk in this situation
because you could write a check at any
minute and pay it off if you got in a
pinch you don't really need the money in
one way or the other it's all about you
know what is your end goal when you're
85 do you want to have a mortgage you
know why would you keep it there's no
reason to keep it you wouldn't go borrow
on a paid for house in order to have
more money to invest and so write a
check and sleep better tomorrow tonight
tonight pay it off tonight hit the
submit button and then when you go and
you get the mortgage release in the mail
make a copy of it take your shoes off
walk into the backyard have a mortgage
burning party and tell me that didn't
feel good I mean there's just no there's
just no downside to this um you know
you're a millionaire you're going to
you're going to be okay either way if
you don't follow our advice if you
follow those idiots advice but if I've
got a financial person that's telling me
to stay in debt I'm getting a new
Financial person
period because George we studied 10,167
millionaires the number of them that
told us that they became wealthy because
they borrowed on their home in order to
invest was precisely zero none of them
leveraged their personal residents to
build their wealth none of them and so
the idea that I continue to leverage my
personal residence in the name of
Building Wealth is asinine based on the
millionaire data well we're seeing so
much more of this because people have
their record low mortgage rates they
don't want to let go of Dave like why
would I pay off my mortgage you know but
I got your mortgage rate beat you know
what my mortgage rate is zero I don't
have one hello heck of a rate zero I got
the best rate come on man so when go up
and down you don't have to worry about
them cuz you don't need debt anymore
it's a great feeling instead of worrying
about what the Market's doing so yes it
hurts to write that check and lose that
much money lose quote unquote but you
never really had it if you owed it to
the lender in the first place Paul pay
it off son pay it off you you're there's
a bunch of intangibles that you're not
even considering in this decision you're
still acting like it's primitive math um
or at least the idiots advising you are
so you you're going to sleep different
your wife's going to look at you like a
hero never never once have we had a wife
said you know my husband borrowed deeply
on our mortgage and he's my hero never
came up
I love the Kermit Vibes she had too
there was great